thanks to Canon for sponsoring a portion
of this video this is a one terabyte
micro SD card it's insane that we can
fit so much data onto something small
enough to eat
this on the other hand is a floppy disk
or what some of you might call the save
button it holds 1.44 megabytes of space
but how many of these could equal this
well let me tell you well for one and a
half million dollars we acquired 700
happiness look how glorious this deck is
it's so tall I don't know man this seems
really unstable I think it might fall I
mean it might but you know what it's not
real we'll be fine come with me on a
journey into the past and the future as
I use visual effects and accurate math
to show you something you've never seen
before the true scale of data no no no
[Music]
most of you are probably familiar with
memory cards we put them in our cameras
to store the photos and videos that we
capture such as the EOS r10 because this
portion of the video is sponsored by
Canon are you a Creator looking to up
your game well guess what the Canon EOS
r10 is a pretty great camera Canon took
the best features of their R series and
put them in a super lightweight body
like this dude
so lightweight but you're like ah this
is 2022 I want high resolution well
guess what you get it this shoots 4K
video and if you're shooting photos
24.2 megapixel Stills I got my own start
in film using a Canon camera a lot like
this and this is so much better for one
thing the autofocus is lightning fast
you literally just like point at
anything and it's already focused before
your brain even knows what it happened
it's a mirrorless camera and it pairs so
nicely with Canon RF lenses also this
thing will actually shoot for longer
than 30 minutes I've been using these
types of cameras for long enough that
like that's actually a big deal if you
are interested click that link down in
the description to check out the Canon
EOS r10 thanks to Canon again for
sponsoring this portion of the video but
let's get back to the episode because I
want to show you my first memory card
about 15 years ago I invested in a
massive one gigabyte memory card for my
camera which was a big deal back then
for a kid like me however these days if
I saw one on the street next to a
quarter I'll be honest I'm probably more
likely to pick up the quarter the gig
just doesn't really have much value
anymore it's hard for me to wrap my head
around the fact that although these are
roughly similar in size one holds a
thousand times more than the other I
mean imagine showing this to a computer
scientist 60 years ago it'd blow their
minds a computer that can fit into a
single room and hold millions of pieces
of information Jesus the scale of just
how big our data storage has gotten is
nearly impossible to imagine it's that
big so megabytes gigabytes you probably
already understand these terms but do
you know what a zettabyte is these terms
help us deal with huge numbers by
putting them into groups of a thousand
so a thousand bytes is a kilobyte a
thousand kilobytes is a megabyte a
thousand megabytes is a gigabyte
thousand you get the idea but what's
above this
well it goes petabyte then exabyte then
zettabyte which is a billion terabytes
this is literally incomprehensibly large
but don't worry we'll revisit zettabytes
before this video is over it's easy to
take for granted that we stream pretty
much everything we want when we want it
but that wasn't always the case if you
wanted to own movies or music you needed
this optical storage this is a 4K
Blu-ray which can hold 50 gigabytes per
disk so with only a small stack of 20 I
have a terabyte DVDs on the other hand
they only hold five gigabytes per disk
so I need 212 of them to do the same
thing these hold the same amount of data
these two different Stacks here and yes
I know the Blu-rays are like black and
the DVDs are blue whatever I don't get
it what about the CD well at 700
megabytes per compact disc you end up
with a stack about as tall as a person
oh this is a lot heavier than it looks
I'm sure some of you've got like a whole
terabytes worth of music CDs stashed
away in those little pocket binders I
know I'm looking at you oh gosh
it's called the compact disc truthfully
I didn't realize the CD first came out
back in 1982. that was
seven when they crossed 200 billion
units sold maybe it's just hard for my
brain to accept that a computer
technology can be so integrated into
society without Ever Changing let's do a
show of hands how many of you have a CD
player in your car but as with all
change it took a while for the CD to
actually like catch on in 1994 Bill
Gates advertised the value of the kind
of brand new but invented 12 years ago
technology by sitting on 330 000 sheets
of paper the idea is actually very
similar to this video he demonstrated
you can store thousands of books worth
of information in the palm of his hand
look at all the paper I'm saving says
the guy literally wasting paper the
photo was taken 28 years ago so I think
it's time to update the comparison
however instead of holding a CD I'm
gonna be holding a one terabyte memory
card so now the question is how tall is
the paper going to be well if we assume
Williams calculations are correct a
sheet of paper can hold 2.12 kilobytes
of information now I can easily afford
the 470 million pages of paper but no
one could give me an answer on how to
safely hold me Steady at 26 kilometers
altitude they said it was like too
dangerous or something stupid like that
man I was really looking forward to
chilling at the cruising altitude of the
SR-71
so why was the CD such a big deal well
it marked the change to optical storage
from magnetic storage have you ever seen
what's inside of a floppy disk it's
basically the same kind of stuff as
what's inside of VHS and cassette tape
because it stores data magnetically but
the data here is coiled into a spiral
disk hence floppy disk this is the form
factor most of us are familiar with but
they actually started out way larger and
held way less and inside of these hard
plastic shells they were indeed floppy
the shells helped to prevent dirt from
becoming a problem 1.44 megabytes is all
that these things held that's not even
enough to hold the average amount of
data a person generates every single
second during the space age of NASA
scientists had to get creative with how
to store memory they use these
hand-woven bits of wire and carbon Rings
called core memory how did it work I
actually honestly have no idea hey I'm
sorry I'm a mechanical engineer not
electrical but according to Scott manlet
it could fit a few terabytes worth of
core memory into the actual buildings
used to build Rockets this right here is
a single bit given to me by Adam Savage
when I visited his shop earlier this
year it was invented for the IBM 604 a
computer so Advanced it could do
subtraction plus multiplication and
division state of the art stuff back
then a bit is the smallest form of data
possible it can only store on or off yes
or no one or zero it's binary which
means to hold any useful amount of
information you need eight of them to
store a single byte this right here is
just enough Hardware to contain the
information of a single character of
text we know that a sheet of paper can
hold a couple kilobytes of data at eight
bits per byte that means seventeen
thousand bits can hold the same
information as this
suddenly a piece of paper seems pretty
dang efficient huh but what would a
terabyte look like this is 8 trillion
bits
[Music]
[Music]
74 years ago a terabyte was um
challenging but honestly these days it's
kind of nothing I mean our studio deals
with hundreds of terabytes in fact I
think the server we have here at
Corridor is the biggest on YouTube uh
maybe not the biggest but we've all got
to start somewhere right oh okay yeah no
that's pretty big uh yeah I mean it
isn't that big though not that I'm
jealous or anything a petabyte is just
one step above a terabyte so Linus's
server is really two and a half thousand
terabytes in size which I happen to have
right here
[Music]
now these are all 3D printed because my
order of two and a half thousand micro
SD cards got lost in the mail in theory
though this is how big Linus's server
could be so Linus what are you doing man
wasting all that space come on this is
this is actually very satisfying
fun fact though this is around the same
data capacity as our brains seriously
add up all the synapses it's about two
and a half petabytes so now I'm just
wondering why doesn't Linus use this as
his server you're actually not the first
to think of using a pile of commodity SD
cards to build out a storage array in
fact we did a video about it four and a
half years ago unfortunately there are a
number of problems with this approach
first and foremost being that it's just
not cost effective a one terabyte SD
card that's affordable enough that large
video productions would generally
consider them to be disposable a
thousand of them yeah
not so much that's about nine times the
cost of a petabyte of traditional
mechanical hard drives a hard drive or
even a regular SSD will often begin
spitting out errors weeks or even months
before it dies out right giving you time
to hopefully back up your data SD cards
well
they just die and with a thousand plus
of these things you are pretty much
guaranteed to have regular failures and
the maintenance that goes along with
them at that point why wouldn't you just
buy proper ssds or hard drives in the
first place
right but we have all these massive
corporations creating dozens of massive
multi-billion dollar data centers to
host all of your content and this
network of hard drives is called the
cloud here it is this is your future but
where's the fun in that I mean I bet
they save so much space with all these
unfortunately these companies are so
secretive about their data capacity they
even hide the exact size and power
consumption of their data centers so we
can't even extrapolate how many hard
drives they must have John John
I tried to hire someone to sneak into a
data center for me to find out but no
apparently that's illegal or whatever
that means so no I don't know exactly
how many hard drives make up the cloud
of one of these companies however I do
think they're each in the ballpark of
around 30 exabytes if they're not there
now they will be very soon trust me
that's 30 000 petabytes or 30 million
terabytes if they use micro SD cards
they could condense their entire cloud
and to adjust this see they're wasting
so much space when they could just have
this and call it a day come on guys if
you need any help I've got extras okay
it wouldn't be a scale video if I didn't
show you the max What's the total amount
of data storage in the entire world
again it's kind of a tricky number to
find there's a difference between the
amount of data being generated
replicated and deleted and the actual
installed data capacity crazily enough
ninety percent of all data never ends up
getting saved but if you were to count
up all of the hard drives memory cards
phones smart hot tubs and everything
else in 2022 we would end up with 10
zettabytes see I told you we'd come back
to zettabytes 10 zettabytes is 10
billion terabytes and a billion is
already such a huge number I made a
whole video about it so 10 billion
memory cards well it cost over one
trillion dollars
and here it is 10 billion memory cards
yeah that's right they fit in a single
tennis court that is a lot of memory
cards but I don't know I guess I was
just kind of expecting it to be a lot
larger after all this does hold the
entire world's data it's really a
testament to how insanely data dense
memory cards have become it's almost
disappointing because I wanted something
truly gargantuan to show you but it's
probably a bad idea to get a little
crazy isn't it
hell no it's not a bad idea that's right
we're going there I had to know the bits
80 billion trillion of these could store
everything and it should be arriving
right about now
[Music]
this Celestial bit is so large that its
own gravity takes over collapsing itself
into a Mini Moon two and a half thousand
kilometers wide this thing is four
million times larger than the asteroid
that ended the dinosaurs
a Planet Killer or a tennis court both
contain the same amount of information
just in very different ways it seems
like we can't possibly get more data
dense than this but let's not forget the
ultimate data storage technology DNA
because a double helix strand of human
DNA contains 215 petabytes of
information but that's just one we have
1.7 quadrillion strands of DNA in our
bodies you thought ten zettabytes was
big try 370 billion zettabytes that's
the data capacity we each carry with us
every day because we are the ultimate
thumb drives
I think technology still has a long way
to go before beating biology
I hope thank you so much for watching it
feels great to be making these
making these series for your viewing
convenience right here
I guess I'll see you next time when I
visualize the scale of nuclear explosion
but for now I'm going to get back to our
quarter digital live stream every month
I'm back it holds 1.4 megabytes of space
so how many of
oh